hey this is presh to Walker
let's say you need to create a times
table from 1 to 10 for the number 43.
there's a neat trick that makes this a
simple calculation
so here's how it works
43 is the digits 4 and 3. so write these
in two columns as o4 and O3
now all you need to do is reproduce the
times tables for 4 and 3 in two
different columns and write each result
as a two digit number
so for the number 04 we'll write 0408
then we have 12 16 20 24 28 32 36 and
40. we'll do the same thing we'll
reproduce the times table for three but
we'll write each result as a two digit
number so this will be o three o six o
nine then we have 12 15 18 21 24 27 and
30.
so now here's the trick let's split up
the O3 column and just put some space
between these two digits
now let's add up the numbers in the o4
column with the tens digits of the O3
column
so we have o4 plus 0 that's equal to o4
then O8 plus 0 is equal to 08 12 plus 0
is equal to 12. now we have 16 plus 1
which is 17 20 plus 1 is 21 then 24 plus
1 is 25 and we keep adding these results
finally we take the digits that are in
the right hand side which are in the
ones column of the O3 and we just append
these
and that's it we've created a times
table for 43. it's 43 86 129 172 215 258
301 344 387 and 430. wow
let's do another example
let's create a times table for 87.
so 87 is made up of the digits 8 and 7
which will write as 08 and O7
now we reproduce the times table for 08
writing each result as a two digit
number we do the same thing for O7
number
now for O7 we'll split this up so we
have some space between the tens and the
ones column
now we will add up the numbers in the O8
column with the tens digits of the 07
column
so we have 8 17 and we just keep adding
these up it's very simple calculation
and finally we just copy over these
numbers from the ones column and we've
created a times table for 87 87 174 261
348 435 522 609 696 783 and 870. it's
that simple
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]